what we're going to do in this video is
review what we know about line plots but
apply them in a situation where some of
our data involves fractions so they tell
us the lengths of some caterpillars are
shown below and so we can see that here
in the line plot just to refresh our
minds how to read a line plot this tells
us that we have two caterpillars that
are four centimeters long these three
show that we have three caterpillars
that are seven centimeters long each dot
represents a caterpillar whose length we
are measuring and it allows us to see
how those lengths are distributed so for
example we have a lot of caterpillars at
this length what is that length well we
can see that it is exactly halfway
between four and five so that is four
and 1/2 centimeters long we divide the
section between four and five into two
equal sections and we're going one of
those two equal sections towards five so
this is four and a half centimeters so I
can ask you some questions how many
total calop caterpillars were measured
pause this video and think about that
well each dot represents a caterpillar
measurement so we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 so we have a
total of 17 caterpillars now another
question we could ask ourselves is how
many of the caterpillars are 5 and 1/4
centimeters long pause the video and
think about that well 5 and 1/4 it's
going to be more than 5 and what we
would want to do to get to 5 and 1/4 is
divide the interval or the length
between 5 and 6 into four equal sections
they already did that 1 2 3 4 so and
then we want to go one of those 4 equal
sections so 5 and 1/4 is right over here
and we can see that there's one
caterpillar that is 5 and 1/4
centimeters long we can ask ourselves
other questions
how many caterpillars let me write it
over here
how many have lengths have lengths
more than
six and 1/2 centimeters pause the video
and try to answer that
so where is six and a half centimeters
well we can divide the section between
six and seven into two equal sections
and if you go one of those two equal
sections that is six and a half so that
is six and a half right over there how
many have a length more than or greater
than six and a half centimeters well we
can see it right over here one two three
four five six six of them do and we
could even try to answer questions like
how many more have a length of nine and
a half centimeters then five and 1/4
centimeters try to answer that question
well nine and a half centimeters that's
halfway between nine and ten right over
there we can see two of them have a
length of nine and a half centimeters
and we already know that one of them has
a length of five and 1/4 so how many
more have nine and a half centimeters
versus five and 1/4 well that would be
two minus one or one more we have one
more caterpillar where the length of
nine and a half centimeters then we do
with five and 1/4 I'll leave you there
we have plenty of examples on Khan
Academy for you to practice this